hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about
cellular senescence and its relationship
with alzheimer's disease
so pretty much i recently read this
nature review article
that discussed this interaction as the
egg and the chicken scenario
so in this video i'll break down both
what selena senescence is and
alzheimer's diseases and then try and
describe
or at least explain what we currently
think may be the link between the two
and where more research needs to be
focused on in the future
so alzheimer's disease is a progressive
decline in memory that ultimately
results in a loss of daily function and
death
and so currently around 35 million
people
are living with alzheimer's disease and
that number is expected to increase
to 135 million by 2050
and so alzheimer's disease is the most
common
neurodegenerative disease and so a lot
of research has been conducted to try
and understand
how the disease manifests and therefore
how
we can best be able to treat and to
prevent
the development of alzheimer's disease
and its symptoms
to be able to do this though you need to
be able to understand the molecular
characteristics
and the processes involved in the
progression of alzheimer's disease
which is easier said than done so what's
our current understanding of the
development of alzheimer's disease
well there are two key hallmarks that
kind of characterize
the presence of alzheimer's disease and
that is firstly the generation of
a region of the brain referred to as the
hippocampus and within this region
you see an accumulation of so-called
amyloid beta plaques
that are found outside of a cell and you
see these neurofibrillary towel tangles
inside a cell and so these are both
protein aggregates
and firstly the loss of proteostasis
and accumulation of protein aggregation
is one of the hallmarks of aging
which given that alzheimer's disease is
an age-related
disease that is a good indication
as to the molecular underpinning of the
disease
but it still doesn't really give us much
information as to how the disease
develops
and this is heightened by the fact that
you can see abnormal tau
within the brain tissue of 98 of
unaffected individuals
and likewise you can see the presence of
amyloid beta
in patients that also don't have the
symptoms of alzheimer's disease
and so another way that you can try and
understand the causes of the disease is
by looking at patients who are at
greater risk of getting certain diseases
because they contain certain genetic
mutations
and so this class of alzheimer's disease
is referred to as familial
alzheimer's disease and this is in
contrast to sporadic alzheimer's disease
which is caused by a combination of
lifestyle environmental and probably
also genetic factors
the unfortunate reality though is that
we still don't fully understand what
causes alzheimer's disease
and this is somewhat reflected in the
many failures seen
for alzheimer's disease treatments
within clinical trials
interestingly though in human patients
there is also an increase in the
presence of senescent cells within the
brain
during aging and moreover there has been
some pretty recent studies
done in mice models of alzheimer's
disease whereby the removal of senescent
cells
helps to reduce the alzheimer's disease
related phenotype that you see in mice
so before we go any further we just need
to
recap what is cellular senescence well
cellulosin essence is best described
through its two major hallmarks
the first of which is the arrest of the
cell cycle
so the cell stops dividing and the
second major hallmark
is the secretion of various factors
including signaling molecules and
inflammatory factors
and this is referred to as the
senescence-associated secretory
phenotype
so given that increasing age increases
the number of senescent cells
and also that increasing age increases
the pathology
and the risk potential for the
development of alzheimer's disease
is it possible then that senescent cells
could contribute to the pathology of
alzheimer's disease
or could the pathology of alzheimer's
disease induce senescence
so we'll begin by looking at some of the
experimental evidence
and then we'll come to some conclusion
about this crosstalk between senescence
and alzheimer's disease
so the brain isn't just composed of
neurons it's also composed of glial
cells
and these cells include astrocytes
microglia
and oligodendrocytes and the precursors
for these illegal dendrocytes
apc cells and the progenitor cells
are the major proliferative cells found
within the brain
whereas the neurons themselves are
generally post-mitotic so they don't
divide
and the microglia are considered more
immune cells of the brain
and play a key role in kind of pruning
and managing the neurons
and so the reason that i just mentioned
this is because the research papers
so show that these different types of
neuronal cells can become senescent
and whether or not it's just due to a
lack of studies and it's just what's
been reported
but what's been shown is that the towel
pathology seen in alzheimer's disease
has been related to senescence within
microglia and astrocytes
whereas amyloid beta plaques have been
associated with
senescence opc cells
so i mean that's interesting just to
point out because it suggests that
maybe different glial cell types are
differentially susceptible
to entering a senescent state so since
2018
several publications have highlighted
the clearance of senescent cells as a
new potential
therapeutic approach to alzheimer's
disease associated neurodegeneration
so in this first research paper that
came out in 2018
they showed that clearance of senescent
astrocytes
and microglia in a mouse model of
tauropathy
so this is when you have the gene that
encodes the tau protein mutated
which makes it more prone to aggregation
and it's just one of the ways that
well it's one of the mouse models that
are used to try and understand
alzheimer's disease pathology and so by
clearing these
senescent cells in this mouth model it
alleviated the formation
of these neurofibrillary towel tangles
and
it had also a consequent improvement in
cognition
and so the way that they were able to
remove these senescent cells is by using
a genetic reporter
referred to as the ink attack reporter
and so this cleared cells that had very
high expressions of p16 which is
a protein that accumulates within
senescent cells
so the fact that the removal of
senescent cells reduced the alzheimer's
disease
phenotype suggests that the senescent
cells were playing a role in the
initiation
and progression of this tau mediated
disease suggesting that here senescent
cells
could be a potential cause of
alzheimer's disease pathology
and this is further supported by the
fact that they saw the accumulation
of these p16 positive senescent glial
cells
before they saw the deposition of these
neurofibrillary tail tangles
and so similar results were seen within
the second 2018 paper
towel protein aggregation is associated
with cellulosin essence in the brain
and so similarly here they use different
alzheimer's disease transgenic mouse
models
and they found that the presence of
neurofibrillary tail tangles
but not the amyloid beta plaques display
a senescence senescence-like phenotype
and they showed that by using cinelytics
and removing the senescent cells
they found that there was a reduction of
these neurofibrillary towel tangles
and so both papers although they show
evidence of removing senescent cells and
reducing the
alzheimer's disease pathology suggesting
that
senescent cells are a cause of the
pathology especially in this last
paper i just showed you it also suggests
that the presence of this alzheimer's
disease pathology
can also potentially induce the further
production of senescent cells
and so there definitely seems to be a
crosstalk and it's more about what is
the signal that
induces the cell to become senescent in
the first place or what is the signal
that
induces this protein aggregation and
towel is it the senescent cells or is it
some
additional factor that's actually you
know inducing both for them
and this question still hasn't really
been solved even in this
more recent 2019 study cellulitic
therapy alleviates amyloid
beta-associated
lego dendrocyte progenitor cell
senescence and cognitive deficits in an
alzheimer's disease model
and so here they showed that the
senescent opc
cells accumulate around amyloid plaque
deposition
in samples of mice and human brains with
alzheimer's disease
and in this study as well they also used
cellulitics
this time the combination of the satin
quercetin
and what that did was reduce the
presence of these senescent opc
cells and they consequently saw a
reduced amyloid beta plaque loads
and improved cognition and just to
clarify the use of
the cellulitics was within the mouse
model
and so one way that we can further tease
apart this cause
and consequence between the two is by
trying
to understand what is this trigger that
is
inducing senescence and these different
neuronal cell types
and so one way of doing this is to go
back to
different genetic variants that
predispose individuals
to develop alzheimer's disease and to
look at what those genes are doing
within a cell
and so just to name two genes one
genetic variant associated with
alzheimer's disease is bin one
and this or the protein encoded by this
gene
regulates senescence activation or
apoptosis in response to genotoxic
stress
by regulating the stabilization of dna
and
another gene is adam ts4
which is a component of this secretary
phenotype of senescent cells
and so it's possible that individuals
carrying variants in these two genes
have a higher risk of alzheimer's
disease potentially due to some
interaction
of these genes with senescence
development an alternative idea
is to look at pathologies within
alzheimer's disease that occurs before
you get the presence of these plaques
and protein aggregates as we know that
senescence senescent cells can
accumulate before these even arise
and so one early pathological event
in alzheimer's disease is the loss of
myelin or neuron cells
and so myelin is an insulating sheath
that surrounds
neuron cells and is deposited mainly by
the illegal dendrocytes
and so when the myelin gets lost and
fragmented
it's then the role of the microglia to
clear this myelin debris
and secrete signaling factors that can
then promote the differentiation of
these opc
cells to become oligodendrocytes to try
and to re-myelinate
if that's even a word the neurons and so
one thought is that if the accumulation
of myelin debris
is greater than the microglial's ability
to
degrade the fragments they can end up
becoming senescent
and release these pro-inflammatory
factors and that could have the advanced
consequence of
one reducing the capability of these
microglia to remove further
fragments but also potentially to reduce
the function of these illegal
dendrocytes that are also in close
proximity and so increased damage
and a reduced capability of microglial
cells could be the cause of senescence
in both the microglial cells themselves
and also
the apc cells and then how this relates
back to
the aed pathology of these tau
aggregates and amyloid beta plaques
is then a little bit less clear because
these plaques are typically found within
the neurons
not within the glial cells and so having
a loss of proteostasis or ability to
remove
these myelin fragments within the
microglial cells
um doesn't really explain why you would
lose the capability of
removing the plaques but actually
honestly i don't really know this isn't
really my area of expertise
so if anyone has any ideas um or has any
other literature that you can recommend
i'm just interested um but yeah that's
pretty much
what i got up to with this review bottom
line is
the answer is just not known in terms of
resolving the chicken and the egg
scenario
and i think it's probably just going to
be a multi-factorial process
with a combination of inflammation
damage
and reduced repair pathways so to speak
and who knows what else is involved
probably different genetic
risk variants as well probably are
playing a part
but the reality is is trying to
understand this is
is going to be really important for
trying to develop
treatments and therapies for the
increasing number of people
who unfortunately will get alzheimer's
disease
so on that kind of sad note i hope you
have learnt something
and as always thanks for listening